[Musique]
nos défenseurs continuent de regagner le
contrôle des régions de kiev et de
tchernihiv il y a de plus en plus de
drapeau ukrainien qui flotte dans les
lieux les enfants profite d'une accalmie
pour s'amuser
pourtant quand les sirènes retentissent
chacun a sa petite technique quand il ya
du bruit qui vient du ciel je vais sous
la couette dans la baignoire je n'ai pas
pauvre je vous propose de commencer ce
discours en nous levant en hommage au
peuple résistant et craignent un pour
une minute de silence
l'otan avec bien sûr les états unis la
première puissance impérialiste au monde
derrière a poussé à pousser ses pions a
installé ses bases militaires et donc va
chatouiller à la russie de poutine
depuis déjà des années et des années ce
qui provoque régulièrement des tensions
qu'est ce qu'il fout là votre
chroniqueur
je le découvre à naulleau si la forêt ce
n'est pas notre candidat va parler
d'eric zemmour est comme moi j'aime bien
les précisant journal du hard c'est
quelqu'un qui a le coeur sur la marche
j'ai listé tournée des accords avec les
riques avec eric zemmour avec ebs mais
je me dis je voterai pas pour lui et si
marine demain si marine demain elle
faisait des concessions je le lui dis
donc se passer je dis pas des choses ici
que je lui ai pas dit si elle faisait
des concessions à eric sur ses
désaccords là ce sera sans doute en
partie la campagne présidentielle
s'achève dernier meeting pour les
candidates sur la forme c'est un très
beau meeting un bravo à mckinsey on sent
qu'il ya des efforts de réalisation et
la rade confession la forme ce meeting
je sais pas la dernière sur la dernière
campagne présidentielle c'est mc kinsey
qu'avait conseiller emmanuel macron il
ya eu manifestement un peut-être un
renvoi d'ascenseur qui était assez
généreux de la part de l'état puisqu'ils
ont bénéficié de beaucoup de marchés
publics mais nous nous sommes habitués à
ce que l'extrême droite se réclament de
charles de gaulle
alors que tout dans son histoire son
parcours l'éloignent du gaullisme elle
est précisément l'héritière de ceux qui
ont combattu le général le concept
d'extrême droite aujourd'hui ne sert pas
à décrire mais a décrié il ne sert pas à
qualifier mais à disqualifier g et ce
concept étouffe la vie démocratique en
transformant en est fréquentable et en
monstres des propositions politiques
dont on peut débattre ils sont
transparents que le règne de
l'infréquentabilité gray a laissé un
seul monsieur qui vient les dom tom et
la saint jean
il n'est pas trop tard parce que depuis
six mois on nous dit déjà que tout est
joué et bien non rien n'est joué tant
que le vote n'a pas eu lieu j'attends
votre pouvoir de tourner cette page et
de faire de nouveau parler des sujets
qui intéressent tout le monde qui
concerne notre vie qui concerne l'avenir
de la planète et celui de nos familles
lorsque marine le pen va être présidente
de la république française ah bon alors
là vous commencez les débats il a passé
la main mais vitaux c'est ce que dit par
exemple manuel valls matin dans le
journal du dimanche il dit marine le pen
peut-être présidente il est minuit moins
une de son point de vue ou emmanuel
macron hier encore qui dans son meeting
dit cela peut advenir c'est un vrai
comédien c'est un homme de théâtre
on a dit que monsieur céline ce qui
était un comédien qui était devenu un
président mais elle m'a conseillé
linverse il était président il est
devenu un vrai acteur de théâtre
pourquoi jeu extrêmement rare que je
sois d'accord ac et edouard philippe
manuel valls et manuela et surtout en
même temps
mais ils ont raison marine le pen peut
gagner emmanuel macron et et le et le
candidat et le président de la
désagrégation de la france de la
destruction de la france il veut que la
france soit dissoute dans l'europe sur
le plan institutionnel et dans l'afrique
sur le plan démographique depuis
maintenant une semaine depuis strasbourg
en gros j'entends une petite musique on
vous aime bien jean nassan mais on n'ira
même pas voté pour vous parce que 1 2
participer au système un nouveau trappe
en s'abstenant à un stress chez nous